[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and
tonight i have what is probably
the best performance at a chess
tournament of all
time i did some googling before the show
and um
the the records differ on what the
actual highest performance rating
tournament is because of course ratings
change uh and have been inflated in the
past
20 years but this one fabiano carijuana
i think an over 3100 performance rating
at the 24 or the 2014 singh field cup
and some of the best chess games i have
ever seen
and to start with here we're going to
take a look at one of those best chess
games ever
between fabiano caruana and levon
ironian in that tournament
now a lot of people uh while this event
was live were
uh you know giving a lot of credit to
fabi's opening preparation as a reason
uh for why he was doing so well and i
want to talk about that as we get into
this game here so we start with e4
e5 fabi plays knight f3 knight c6
and the oldest opening in chess or
almost
uh bishop b5 the roy lopez we get a6
bishop a4
and normal stuff with knight f6 no
berlin
this time we get castles by whites
bishop b7 by levon
d3 b5 bishop b3
castles and knight c3 so
a normal closed roy lopez position here
with fabi opting for
knight c3 rather than the slightly more
common c3
when everybody has seen this kind of
game plan before
instead we get knight c3 and with this
move uh fabi is taking a more direct
approach
to controlling the d5 square of course
after
c3 you can expect things like the
marshall with this move d5 by black
so that's the first sort of deviation
from the
you know main line of the roy of course
knight c3
also a very respectable move then we get
d6 by levon
normal stuff still a3 by fabi
controlling the b4 square
and hinting at a potential expansion
over here later on
now we see knight a5 for black
and another bonus of a3 is that our
bishop has a little square
to run away from this threat bishop e6
by levon and then here's where fabi very
much
goes off the beaten path so generally
you get knight d5
or the move b4 here from white
in this instance though fabi does
capture on e6
and we see f takes e6 uh in return
by levon aronian now why isn't bishop
takes e6
as common well for one it allows black
to control the center square d5
much more easily and number two it does
open up this f file which can
occasionally
be useful for black now what does white
get in return
well of course double pawns always come
with certain inherent weaknesses
we're going to see fabia actually look
to target those in the game
now b4 was played we see levon play
knight to c6
bishop d2 is still very normal now d5
by levon we see rook e1
and now queen d6 by by levon ironian and
i chose this moment
to pause because up to this point they
had actually been following a game
uh by lenie dominguez and sergey
karyakin
that was played earlier in 2013 of
course this tournament in 2014
and i think we need to look at that game
to understand fabi's next moves
uh in this current game so so far we've
had some pretty normal opening play
i'm sure both players were familiar with
this game that they're following
a game by the way that was won by sergey
karjakin with the black pieces
uh and so lavon is probably thinking you
know this worked well for sergey
the plan seemed to make sense there i'm
going to do the same thing
but fabi i'm sure had seen this game and
actually came up with a pretty
significant improvement
over what lenia dominguez played so in
that game
lenny a chose this move h3 and this is a
pretty interesting move because
at first glance you're not really sure
what it's doing if you're
looking at it from from the perspective
of the white pieces but
of course the idea with h3 is generally
to give
one of these knights the h2 square and
in the roy lopez
this is a very common idea you get a
knight to h2 so you can reroute it
to g4 now how does this make sense with
white's plan well we already said these
pawns are going to be a little bit weak
because they're doubled
so it makes sense to reroute a knight
here get rid of this f6 defender
and combine some kind of attack on the
king's side
with threats against these pawns in the
center
however this didn't really work out for
lenient dominguez because in that game
sergey played very very well with knight
d7
now we get knight e2 by lenier
perhaps again hinting at some ideas
of attacking the center now a5 by
uh black was played in the game
and after this move a5 it's very very
clear that whatever
kind of play lenie was hoping for on the
king's side it's going to be a bit
overshadowed
by sergey being able to rip open the
queen's slide pretty immediately and
that's exactly what happens
rook b1 was played in that game takes
takes work fb-8
knight g3 but now black closes the
center
and invades on the a file and black of
course had a pretty significant
advantage
thanks to these center pawns controlling
a lot of squares and activity
down the a file so fabi took a look at
that game and said i can do better
and that's why in this position rather
than the slower move h3
fabi takes a very proactive approach to
stopping
levon ronin's plan on the queen side and
he does so with a very counterintuitive
move
knight a2 so what's going on with this
move
well immediately fabi is increasing
increasing the pressure
to the a5 pawn and in fact is just
planning a very simple reroute to b3
ensuring that the queen side is going to
stay locked down forever
uh levon aronian plays this same
preparatory move that we saw sergey
karjakin play
the immediate a5 is potentially playable
but it does
run into some tactics here for example
knight back to c3 hits b5
or fb8 and then there's stuff like
knight takes e5
that lavon would have to look out for
with the idea of the bishop coming to f4
and pawn to d4 to follow maybe not a
huge advantage for white
but definitely something you need to
calculate
and so levon perhaps fearing this does
play the move knight f to d7
uh the same movie so circa carrier can
play and now queen e2 by fabi
so very accurate stuff so far all very
much with the intent
of stopping this move of a5 now
queen e2 and a5 don't really seem to be
that related to each other so let's take
a look at what happens again if a5 here
i think fabi would simply capture we get
knight takes a5
because the bishop covers now ed5 ed5
rook b1 is again a useful move stepping
off this diagonal
and attacking the b5 pawn rig fb8 and
it's just that same tactic that we saw
earlier
except this time the knight is already
defended no need for bishop f4 tricks
white is just taking this pawn and with
it getting a lot of activity
down the center e file so so far
fabi's digression from lennie a's game
has been knight a2
knight fd7 and again queen e2 now
and with these moves uh fabi seems to
have found a tactical way
to keep this plan of a5 from happening
immediately
and how is fobby going to spend that
time well we'll see after the move d4
and so d4 of course might not be the
most intuitive move at first
but the idea is to negate these e takes
d threats
pressuring e5 all in an attempt to get
this a5 push through
now we see rook f rook e to b1 by fabi
so some counter-intuitive mysterious
rook moves here
by fabi but when you understand what
their purpose is
it's it's quite nasty what fabi is doing
here
he puts the rook on the e file to make
these threats stopping a5
lavon closes the center threatening to
play a5 again the rook has served its
purpose
so now it moves to b1 and in turn
pressures the b pawn
stopping a5 once again now we see knight
b6
by levon aronian trying to invade to
these weakened squares
but this allows fabi the time he needs
to play knight c1
and knight b3 effectively shutting down
lavon's play
on the queen's side forever and i would
say this
is the genius opening play that people
were sort of talking about at the time
bobby had clearly done quite a bit of
work on this line in particular
and even similar lines understood at its
core that black needs to play this move
a5 to get activity on the queen's side
and did
everything in his power to stop that
from happening and has now succeeded
that being said that is only stage one
in this game uh we we've had a lot to
talk about so far
with just the opening play and what has
fabi done
with uh with this opening skill well
he's gotten himself about a plus point
three advantage
according to my stock fish at least so
clearly
the game is not winning yet but fabi so
deeply understands the plan in this
position that he knows
now that a5 has been prevented black is
going to have a
very very difficult game because if
you're not playing a5 here
what are you doing with the black pieces
well
it's very natural that the von eronian's
attentions were turned to the open f
file if or if fabi is not going to let
lavon play the move a5 if he has so
directly
uh positioned all of his pieces to
prevent this from happening
well then levon is going to switch sides
to the board and starts with rook
f7 now we're going to get another
subtlety
by fabi here once again this rook served
its purpose on the e
file now it's not really needed on the b
file with the knight
stations on b3 and so we see the move
rook c1
uh and it took me a while to understand
why rook c1 was played but this is
actually
sort of a trap by fabi if lavonne were
to play the natural move
rook a to f8 then fabi is actually ready
to break open the c
file here and now that lavon's rooks
have been diverted to the f-file
fabi is going to have a pretty nice
advantage with the opening of the c file
in these slightly loose pieces and
that's why we see levon
who's a very good chess player playing
rook d8 instead with the idea of
preventing any c4
or c3 breaks by fabi by including some
pressure down the d-file
now we see the move knight g5 hitting
this rook hitting this pawn
we get rook f6 by levon ironian not
quite ready to part with this bishop
perhaps fearing some of these dark
squared weaknesses on the queen side
we get queen h5 now by fabi inducing a
weakness
with h6 and simply knight back to f3
and already the the opening pressure uh
that fabia has put on is really being
felt
um so no more uh are these days of the
lennie dominguez sergey karjakin game
where white
never really got off the ground on the
king's side we saw lenie immediately
defending the b-pawn
sergei immediately getting active rooks
on the a file and pretty much the entire
game happened on the queen's side of the
board
now fabi's queen is already on h5 he's
already induced a weakness with h6
and these pawns are already under some
pressure
uh and that is the power of bobby's
opening even though he wasn't winning
out of the opening he maneuvered the
game steered the game
into a position where white's plan is
clear direct
and very uh difficult to meet and
black's plan is a little bit
lackluster you can put you can put these
rooks on the f file and levon does do
this
but what is your purpose on the f file
not so clear
now for the third time in the game the
rook has served its purpose
on c1 and now switches places to go back
to f1 so
if ever there was a game of mysterious
rook moves this was it
with the rook starting on f1 going to e1
b1 c1 and now back to f1
but when we look at them step by step
they do start to make
quite a bit of sense now of course the
rook simply defending this pawn on f2
and negating the pressure that levon is
putting on the f file
now we're going to see the move rook 8
to f7 by lavon
and this one is a little bit over my
head i think perhaps
levon is looking to be able to play a
move like bishop f8
if it's needed to defend perhaps also
giving the king an escape route
i don't fully understand it but it's not
a bad move according to the engine
and i will take the engine's word on
that one
perhaps also uh we'll we'll see lavon
has a g6 idea a little bit later and
it's nice to have the rook in front of
the king then
to uh be able to maneuver around now we
get rook
a to e1 by fabi this one is a little bit
less mysterious to me
the rook not doing anything in the a
file is just moving into the game
uh bishop f8 now by lavonne again
perhaps this is just the simple idea
although i don't really know how this
occurred to levon uh
but regardless not a bad idea
now we see the move h3 by fabi and
this is the move that fabio originally
had diverted away from
in lenie's game but we see that lenient
didn't really have a bad idea
it was just mistimed now and only now
that fabi has locked down the entire
queen side
forced lavon to divert the pieces back
to the king's side
is fabi playing these advancing
aggressive moves
like h3 to allow for maneuvers like
knight h2 to g4
now we see g6 by levon aronian and again
i don't know how he came up with this
idea but if you look at this position
for black
it's honestly quite difficult to come up
with anything better
knight c3 isn't really doing anything
and it might actually be captured by
white
this knight i guess you could try to
reroute back into the game
somehow maybe some bringing it to b6
but again it's not really with a purpose
it's tough to unify
the black pieces here and that's how
levon is playing these strange looking
moves like rook f7 bishop f8 and g6
that being said the queen's attacked so
fabi simply retreats back to h4
we see queen e7 now uh hinting at the
idea of some queen trades
probably just puts the queen back on g3
and says you're going to have to defend
this pawn for a while
lavonne though is up to the task plays
bishop g7
indirectly defending it and now we have
uh what i'm going to call the move
of the game so fabi first and foremost
has negated the entire queenside idea by
black
no easy task this was black's main plan
and this is generally how players with
the black pieces are playing against
this structure and now fabi has
uh slowly but surely diverted the rooks
back over to the king's side
the bishop is already well placed he's
forced weaknesses with g6 and h6
this weakness he created early early on
with bishop takes e6
how do we pull the trigger now and
launch our attack i'm asking you
chatroom
see if you can find the move here
see if you can find the move
mouses is knight h2 not a bad idea not a
bad idea at all
knight h2 does in fact maintain quite a
significant
advantage for uh for white but we'll see
fabia has something else in mind
knight e5 knight h4 knight g5 okay i
don't know about this one
this one does seem to lose this piece
you get this little pin but black's just
going to step out of the way
what else knight h4 i also don't think
makes the most sense
black might actually be trying to play a
move like g5 in just a little bit
gaining gaining even more space perhaps
the c4 break has been suggested because
the knight on c6 is hanging
i don't know if it's going to really
work out though you do have some work to
do with controlling the c3 square
bishop h6 knight h4 and as expected
nobody in the chat room is as good at
chess
as fabi caruana i don't know why i
thought you would be
that is sort of a high barred across but
fabi of course
of course activates the final piece on
b3
now that it's served its purpose of
preventing the move
a5 and that's really been the theme of
the game here
fabi using his pieces for very direct
very important purposes and realizing
that once that purpose has been
fulfilled there's something better
they can be doing we saw this rook get
improved four different times
early in the opening all with really
strong effects
and now of course we see this knight get
into the game
by playing knight a5 uh so what's going
on here
well this knight is a really important
defender of
the e5 pawn this knight was doing
nothing on b3
aside from stopping a5 which now isn't
really that important with all the
pieces on the king's side
so of course fabi is looking to trade
this piece
for the defender on c6
now those of you with keen tactical eyes
might realize that after knight takes a5
b takes a5 this pawn is hanging um and
those with even keener
tactical vision will realize that
perhaps black can sacrifice a rook here
go king h7 and then play for these
weaknesses
on the queen's side right we've gotten
rid of a lot of the punch
in white's attack by getting rid of this
knight and you know now the queen side
there are weaknesses to be dealt with
here
bishop b4 can be met by c5 and maybe
black's back in the game
and you would be totally correct which
is why we see fabi playing knight takes
e5 in this position
and this is the idea that makes knight
a5
so so strong white is now playing up two
pieces because these two knights are not
impacting the board at all levon
does decide to save this knight in light
of the fact
that if white is able to take on a5 then
white isn't sacrificing anything and
it's still up a ton of
pieces effectively so knight b7 and now
simply knight g6 bobby's not interested
in settling for this lowly rook on f7
we're going to take on g6 and keep up
the pressure
now queen d8 by levon aronian
and e5 by fabi rook f5
and now simply f4 and once again
fabi is effectively playing up
two pieces here with these two knights
just simply not
in the game i guess effectively up one
piece because technically
fabi does happen to be down a piece if
you count this bishop
and these two knights by the way
bishop's not contributing
a whole lot either and now we see the
move c5 by levon aronian
which is a good of try as any you need
to get these knights back into the game
somehow
and so far they are lacking in legal
chess moves that don't immediately hang
them
now we see knight h4 by fabi and he's
simply going to push the pawns forward
continue attacking weaknesses and win
the game in style
knight back to f3 after rook h5 once
again
the knight did its job by careening
through black's position
and taking off the pawns now it comes
back in a more supporting role for the
pawn on e5
king h7 queen g4 hits the rook in the
pawn
so rick h to f5 and now once again
knight to h4
and this rook is simply trapped uh king
h8
fabi does capture the rook now
effectively
fabi has sacrificed one uh
sorry two pieces for one rook but those
two pieces are sitting
on a4 and b7 so basically up a rook here
for fabiano caruana
queen g6 now and you can't stop the pawn
storm
and this game is just over queen e7 g4
rook f8 f5 queen e8
no danger here for fabi simply trades f6
bishop f8 and now even f7 is good enough
fobby finding the accurate tactical
finish after rookie 7
rick f6 knight b6
finally these knights are about to enter
the game again but bishop takes h6 is
good enough to win
we see knight to d7 in the game
and just a few more moves rook e to f1
knight f6 is not going to get the job
done after bishop f8
when this end game is hopeless for black
just three
connected past pawns for white is going
to be enough
um so instead we see c takes b4 by levon
a takes b4 bishop h6 rook h6 check
king g7 and rook h5 was enough for a
resignation
from lavon iranian of course white's
next two moves are rook g5 and rook g8
and then uh the game once again is going
to be over
and rook takes f7 by the way is met by i
think rook h7 first
and then rook f7 picking up the knight
and
actually both knights with the knight on
b7 being totally trapped
so this i claim is one of the best games
of chess ever played and i just want to
take you through step by step what
happened again
so once again of course fabi has
fantastic opening play
and you see that here with this move
knight to a2
such a deep understanding of the
position to realize
that preventing a5 at all costs is going
to give white
an advantage in this position black
stuck to
to the normal plan following the path
that sergey karjakin had laid out in a
previous game
but now after d4 the center is locked
down
thanks to this pressure by fabi we see
him ensuring that a5 never gets played
with knight b3 and this rook completes
its journey
uh to c1 and then eventually
over to f1 and the rest is history fabi
just
launches this stunning attack on the
king side
and that's not opening preparation
that's just fabi being a chess genius
by the way essentially perfect play
during this attack by fabi
and the the star move of the game of
course
knight a5 activating the final piece for
fabi
and sacrificing its inglorious style so
questions on this game because it is
quite a game
it is quite a game questions before we
move on chat
exquisite corpse says the problem with
doubled e pawns
isn't the weak pawns it's the weak
squares and i guess you could argue
that g6 has been really weakened by this
pawn being an e6
i would also argue that this pawn being
weak is
a very large contributing factor to why
fabi won this game so
i don't know if it's fair to say one
over the other but definitely both
uh were important in this game
what opening the roy lopez george it's
the royal lopez all right let us
move along to the second game i want to
look at
which is a game between of course the
world champion magnus carlsen
with the white pieces against fabi
caruana
so a little bit more on the tournament
history here fabi actually started the
tournament
with seven points out of seven and then
i think he decided enough is enough and
he kind of coasted in those last three
games
with three pretty easy draws uh to round
out his tournament
uh but seven out of seven to start with
involved uh
beating the world champion uh with the
black pieces and that's what we're gonna
look at now
uh by the way seven out of seven against
the world's best a feat
not accomplished by many players uh i
think bobby fischer may be the only one
with comparable streaks
but anyways let's take a look here
magnus plays e4
we see fabi play e5 and bishop c4 so by
this point
um i might be wrong in this but i think
fabi was already on a little bit of a
tear here
um i don't think this was like round one
or two i think magnus had seen
bobby's doing pretty well but magnus
being magnus carlsen
was not about to play some quiet game uh
and and really went went after fabi here
so we we get knight f6
d3 and now c6 by favi and this is
generally the problem with the bishop's
opening
by the world champion what's the
difference between the bishop's opening
and the italian well you see in this
position
thanks to the pressure on the e5 pawn
black has already been forced to make a
move
that that defends the pawn whereas with
the bishop's opening that we see here
we see fabi being the aggressor as far
as
knight moves that attacks center pawns
and now thanks to this extra tempo
that black has saved by not defending e5
we see the immediate c6 and black is
able to break in the center
much more easily and much more freely
than in the normal
italian the game does continue with
knight f3
and now we see d5 and traditionally it's
it's thought that once black achieves
this move
against this bishop's opening it's more
or less uh
easy equality for black we see bishop b3
in the game
we get a bishop b4 check c3 and bishop
d6
it's pretty easy to understand why it's
thought that black has a
has equalized in this opening all of
black's pieces are going to have
pretty natural squares black is not
going to have any less space
in the center and hasn't really created
too many weaknesses
to speak of so let's see how magnus
was aiming to shake up the game here so
we get bishop g5
applying a little bit of pressure to
these light squares in the center
fabi simply takes on e4 we get d takes
e4
and now h6 forcing this bishop away
and now queen e7 so stepping off the d
file
and again shaping up to be a pretty
calm game here black is going to develop
this bishop play knight bd7 play rip d
of course castle at some point and it
looks like major piece is probably going
to get traded
on the d file it's going to be one of
those quiet games
that you've actually probably seen uh in
the world championship match between
these two players
uh instead though we get knight bd2
knight bd7
so far so normal bishop g3 bishop c7
pretty normal move stepping off of the
loose d6 square on the open file
we get castles and now fabia's claim to
play for more than equality
comes with this move knight h5
so what's going on with knight h5 well
fob is going to take off
this bishop and then because these are
two 2800 players
uh he'll say bishop pair i win and then
magnus will resign
so that's almost what happens instead we
get h3 knight g3
fg3 and knight c5
now what do you think magnus carlsen
decided to play
after knight c5
what did magnus carlsen decide
to play and after knight c5
now magnus might be a passer that gave
up the bishop pair but he's not going to
be a passer
that gives up his second bishop too
lightly here so
a move like bishop c4 you might think is
very very normal
and it is very very normal but it's not
what magnus decided to play
uh turns out these 2800 players so much
hate
giving up these bishops for knights that
magnus decided he's going to give it up
for a pawn instead and played uh bishop
takes f7
now one of these moves wins and one of
these moves loses
and despite the order i drew those arrow
arrows in
i want to ask you guys which one wins
and which one loses and also
bonus points what was magnus's mistake
in playing bishop takes f7
what did he miss
what did he miss here chatroom
so randy says i would think moving the
king is bad
and that is what you would expect but of
course king takes f7 wins the game
and queen takes f7 loses the game now
why is that
well knight takes e5 comes on the board
and you have a lot of problems that you
need to solve
with this queen here if you move it to a
safe square
you're going to get checked and this
king is stuck very much
in the center of the board which is not
ideal uh king
7 is met by knight g6 and king
to d8 is met by knight f7 and king to d7
is illegal
all the other moves are illegal so so
sad so of course you should play king
takes now
is this what magnus carlson missed no
probably magnus carlsen is good enough
to think
yeah king takes f7 as playable but i i
have some attacked
some kind of attack of course what
magnus carlson missed
that fabiano caruana is a dirty
calculator all this guy does
is calculate long forcing variations and
he's never wrong
uh never in fabiano caruana's life has
he calculated incorrectly and that's
almost true
um and it turns out fabia just
calculated this one
better than magnus and we're gonna see
him now go on to defend
pretty much pretty much perfectly and
this is again uh not necessarily down
to his good opening play as many would
tell you like of course
fabi had a great opening in this game
against magnus
equalized by like move five and had a
slight advantage
of course uh why not continue launching
an attack here
and it looks like leches actually gives
it a question mark exclamation point
bubble
this is like a new thing that leeches
has been doing um
lee chess i think wanted you to play
rook takes f8 or something
i don't know but knight d3 not a bad
move at all
we do get queen takes d3 now bye uh
back up a few moves where the stream
died for just a few moments
uh okay do you know when um
sorry about that was it here uh i think
it was
yeah we're back okay we're back live
i think the stream died for a moment
there
um i was just talking about how great
fabiano caruana is
because he's such a dirty calculator so
queen g5 in this position and i was
showing that rook f8 check for white
king h7 now rookie shape by the way is
met by king g6
so knight takes h8 instead and it
appears
uh at the surface level that
white is up in exchange here and i was
wondering that perhaps
this is where magnus stopped calculating
as i believe this is where many players
might stop calculating
maybe he saw that all the tactics don't
quite work out for black it's not like
white's getting checkmated or anything
but then fabi comes up with this nice
move bishop g4 attacking the rook on f8
and the queen on d1 at first glance this
looks quite strong but of course there
is this
uh strange looking move queen to d3 but
value finds this nice follow-up with
knight d3
and i was just talking about how these
little question mark exclamation point
bubbles
are very new to me by leigh chess uh
okay
so back caught up to where i was knight
d3 really interesting
move by uh fabi and magnus comes up with
the move queen takes d3 which is
probably correct
um if magnus had gotten greedy here and
played something like
rook takes a8 of course fobby's point
was that queen e3 check is going to be
quite strong
when uh you're going to be losing this
queen or simply getting
getting kind of destroyed and checkmated
i don't know if i see direct checkmate
here i guess knight takes e4
is somehow like maiden 7 this is a
pretty simple plan
to put the final nails in the coffin so
fabi effectively defending this we're
going to eat by playing knight t3
and this was enough to convince magnus
to give the exchange
back now though if we count the number
of pieces on the board
uh black is fully even on material
down i believe two pawns this knight on
h8 has seen better days
so that's why we see magnus taking on a
taking on g4
you have to take this piece back or else
you're simply down the knight on h8
and now queen takes g4 by fabi because
he's really really mean
he's not going to take the knight
because it's still trapped
we now see knight f3 by magnus carlsen
not yet really willing to give up on
this attack queen g3
by fabi and before you know it the
material is
back to even fabi miraculously finding
all the tactics
way in advance uh after bishop f7 and is
now simply
much better with the knight on h8
hanging on the next turn
material even and believe it or not the
safer king
after playing king takes f7 king g8 king
h7
we do see e5 check by magnus forsenking
takes h8
and now e6 by magnus carlson but this
unfortunately is rolling over pretty
quickly here fabi finds the accurate
bishop b6 check this king now has to
step to
h1 really no other move
queen g4 now is threatening some stuff
so we see queen to d6 trying to defend
some stuff
of course with some normal move like
rookie 1 here you're going to get
well sorry not queen h5 immediately but
rook takes f3 is sort of the
nasty threat here with stuff like this
going on
so we get queen d6 anticipating these
types of queen checks and also by the
way
attacking a rook and supporting your
pawn simply rook d8 by fabi
forces this queen back and now rook d5
has
activated the rook and checkmate is is
kind of coming
uh queen b8 check king h7 magnus says
i'm gonna go queen fabi says that's fine
i calculated everything again
in this position believe it or not is
actually black to move
and win and there's only one way to do
it
only one way to do it here only one way
to win the game
and of course that move is not rook h5
check that loses what's wrong with you
why would you ever think that fabi's
plan with rook d8 to d5
was rook h5 absolutely ridiculous of
course it's queen h5 check
why is rook hive wrong well simply
knight h2
by white and you really don't have a
good way to
to finish finish the job here blight is
believe it or not not getting checkmated
thanks to this queen on b8
and you don't have a good way to stop
this pawn from promoting
and that's why we see the move uh queen
h5 check
now if queen h2 were to be played fabi's
going to take the slow approach
simply play queen to e8 and pick up this
pawn
in pretty short order here rookie 1 is
met by bishop f2
when you have to stay on the back rank
or else you face the wrath of rook d1
and rook f1 is actually losing uh
losing your queen and sorry you might
just be losing your queen here
uh but there is there is i guess knight
h4 so bishop f2
and then rook h5 quite strong so
magnus didn't like that so magnus chose
knight h2 instead
but this actually loses a bit faster to
rook d1 check
when there's simply nothing to do here
rook takes d1 queen takes d1 knight f1
now we get the queen check king h2 and
only a fool would expect fabiana
carowana to have difficulties
stopping queens and checkmating white
because after queen g1 check
magnus carlsen just resigns no way to
stop
queen e3 and queen takes
g queen takes e7 on the following turn
and this is another game that fabiano
wins that demonstrated
an entirely different skill set to game
number one
game number one he just positionally
crushed levon ironian
and found the nice little combination to
activate his final knight
and then here he just out calculates
magnus carlsen
pretty much effortlessly uh like he
outplays him in the opening sure
fobby great openings as as usual and
then he just out calculates
magnus carlson finds every accurate move
needed to win the game
and is not phased at all by the bishop
sacrifice
in the opening followed by being down in
exchange for a few turns
just just does it uh with ease so really
impressive stuff
by fabio showing entirely different side
of
his opening play and now i want to
demonstrate
a third aspect where fabiano uh was
doing really well in this tournament
with the game against maxime vashila
grav
so to recap game one excellent
positional play
amazing positional understanding by
fabiano just crushes the von eronian by
shutting down black's plans game number
two
just destroys magnus carlsen straight
out of the opening
with amazing calculating abilities
and now game number three we are going
to demonstrate the psychological
advantage
fabi had over all of his opponents once
he had won like six games in a row this
was either game number six or seven
uh up against maxine vashir legrov and
at this point everybody in the
tournament is like looking at fabi
and they're just like please don't hurt
me please don't hurt me so we're gonna
see
mvl essentially just roll over in the
face
of fabi here let's take a look we have
d4
by mvl no more of this e4 stuff okay
fabi clearly knows what he's doing in e4
no roy lopez's
no bishops openings no italians we're
playing d4 and drawing the game
i love it okay so d5 c4
fabi just plays very simply here with
the qgd we get knight c3
bishop e7 and this is a little bit of a
weird move order
i think designed to prevent the qgd
exchange
with bishop g5 of course this prevents
that by
controlling the g5 square so bishop g5
is just not
not a very good move here but
instead mvl just plays bishop f4 which
is also a very normal opening
we get knight f6 now e3 castles
rick c1 knight bd7 again just
very calm stuff so far and then mvl
decides to play c5
kind of kind of randomly here um
and this is something i did a lot as a
1400
i loved pushing my pawn to c5 and
laughing at my opponents for not being
able to control their dark squares
but as i got a little bit better at
chess i was always told
hey this move is kind of bad and we're
going to see why that is
in this game here now is this the reason
why mvl lost
no but i do think this throws away any
type of opening advantage that white
might have
now why is c5 so bad well there's sort
of two reasons
reason number one is it's generally not
a bad idea for black to go a little bit
crazy
and just attack these pawns outright
although we'll see that is maybe not the
best plan
here if you do want to go with b6 you
might actually run into c6
and this is what 1400 me would love to
do
suddenly this knight is essentially just
trapped which is not ideal
so you can go c6 and sort of leave this
leave this plane in your back pocket or
you can do this other plan
that fabian axe in the game starting
with knight e4
we get bishop d3 by mvl now f5
by fabi and we get this kind of
stonewall looking thing
but a really really important part here
is that white is already committed to c5
so it's going to be a lot better
for black for one very specific reason
and that is
control over the e5 square
thanks to the lack of pressure the c5
pawn puts onto black's center
black is much more freely able to play
the e5 break
and with it pretty much solve any
opening problems you would have in a
normal stone wall
of activating this bishop so that's the
second reason why c5 is bad
you need this pressure on d5 to prevent
really appealing breaks like e5 for
black
now we see knight f3 in the game doing a
good job of trying to control e5
regardless
c6 now by fabi we do get 95 95
bishop e5 but after bishop f6
we're going to see that this control
over e5 is not meant to last
for white if you play something like f4
you're sort of asking for trouble
with queen h4 check coming and so mvl
decides he's just going to give up
on this dream of controlling e5 and
takes f6
now we see queen takes f6 by fabi
knight e2 by mvl and just e5
so once again favi seizing a nice
opening opportunity to solve all of his
problems
c5 by mvl a little bit on the weirder
side and fobby understanding
c5 comes with the downside of allowing
the e5 break in many cases
then i'm willing to bet being the dirty
calculator that he is he got to
somewhere around here in his mind and
was like yeah i guess black is fine
now we see the psychological pressure
really taking its toll onto mvl here
now you guys in the chat room at home
might be thinking
hey why don't i castle my king f2 is
attacked
like a billion times like i'm so scared
that something bad is gonna happen on f2
i gotta castle my king
and you would be correct you would be
absolutely correct you guys in the chat
room
might also be thinking why don't i take
on d4 and
use this d4 square for my knight that
looks actually kind of appealing
and you would be right again and
furthermore you guys in the chat room
might even be thinking
why not play something like queen c2
maybe try to build up some pressure on
this diagonal
and that would also be perfectly
acceptable here
for white what you guys at home probably
aren't thinking is hey
why don't i play queen a4
and uh the the good counter argument
to why not play queen a4 is why would
you play queen a4
i don't understand what this move does
and i think this is just
mvl sort of panicking against a really
tough opponent in fabiano carijuana
with an unprecedented winning streak in
this tournament
but yeah queen a4 just doesn't do
anything it
vaguely increases the pressure on the
queen side maybe
mvl was thinking i'll go b4 b5 or
something
but of course when you're staring down a
lot of pieces looking at f2
with f4 breaks in the position you know
you got to be a little bit more cautious
than queen a for
just putting the queen on the exact
opposite side of the board
so i've been talking up this f2 pawn a
lot uh what
does it actually mean that this pawn is
weak well it means we get moves like
queen h4
and these moves are going to induce
weaknesses uh
from white's camp here uh theoretically
white could castle
but then you're actually gonna be
dealing with threats against the h-pawn
as well
and it's sort of just free tempe for uh
fobby here so instead we're going to see
the move g3
trying to deal with the threat this way
but now of course g3 has made all sorts
of other weaknesses
in white's camp queen g4 by fabi
and then weird move number two rook f1
so at this point i understand not
winning the castle having just played
the move g3
but rook f1 is is just a bit too afraid
it's a bit too afraid of fobby
we needed to bring this queen back into
the game why is this queen on a4
nobody knows bring it back to like
literally any square
and it's better placed instead we get
rook f1 and now of course fabi has an
advantage and he's gonna play perfectly
until he wins
and he does so with knight g5 just
immediately
taking advantage of all these weak
squares in white's camp
and the the end is already near for mvl
we see king d2 in the game
knight f3 check king c3 h2 falls
rook h1 knight back to f3
and i could say the rest is history but
that would deprive you guys of a very
entertaining king hunt
that fabi goes on here
so now you might be thinking what's
better than the a4 square for the queen
and if you came up with the a5 square
then you're thinking like mvl
and i don't know if this was his initial
intention with queen a4
it's a very strange one to just try and
invade on the c7 square
but this is the idea he came up with in
the game at this point
uh you can't really fault him uh there's
just no good moves in this position
for white there's there's just nothing
good you can do so queen a5 why not
bobby now plays the move uh queen to g5
applying a little bit of pressure to
these dark squares
we see d takes e5 by mvl
and simply queen e7 now stops queen c7
and is ready to capture on
e5 with either piece uh knight d4
by mvl simply knight takes e5 and c5 is
also weak
we get b3 by mvl another sort of mystery
move here
b3 don't know what the idea was maybe
he's afraid of knight c4 or something
but again i think this is just
the psychological edge uh showing its
stuff here like i
i don't think mvl plays b3 against the
2400 international master
i'll say that much i think you only play
b3 against
uh you know so far 3000 plus performance
uh fabiano carajuana because you're like
i don't see how knight c4 kills me
but fabi just played knight e5 i gotta
stop knight c4 i think that's what's
going on
all right so b3 and now b6 is the
correct idea by fabi
because of course it is c takes b and
simply c5
and immediately any sense of safety you
had with this
king is just entirely gone uh mvl tries
to save this
knight we get bishop b7 now activating
the final piece
and making threats b takes a7
d4 check attacks this king e takes d4
and now bobby first trades off these
pieces simply takes on h1
by the way you can't even take back
that's just so sad
uh instead we get rook takes c5 and fabi
now upper rook
goes about the process of checkmating
the white king
by driving it up the board and
just really mercilessly uh bringing in
the rooks
and ending the game here uh
not even rook takes b6 by the way like
how mean do you have to be
to not play rook takes b6 you have to be
pretty mean
we get queen d3 check and queen d5 check
instead
and this is where uh this is where mvl
decided to throw in the towel
of course if you try something like rook
c6 the simplest is perhaps just to take
it ever
take everything and take on a7 here
when you have no way to save your queen
so this is perhaps the third aspect of
the game
where fabiano was incredibly crushing
everyone he came across
psychologically by calculation uh by
positional
understanding fabi really had it all in
2014
and probably still has those skills
today uh alright we do have some time
left and so there's one more game i want
to go over with you guys even if we only
uh have a few minutes to do so and that
is the game against
vessel and topalov from the same
tournament so
topolof a lot of you guys who are just
getting into chess might not know
but this guy was a beast in the 2000s
and going into the mid-2010s as well you
see a lot less of him these days
i think he might be one of those
technically retired players who still
comes out to play some events
but uh very strong guy played against
vichyanan for the world championship
and very nearly won it and this is his
game against fabiano caruana
so let's take a look we have fabi
playing e4
and topalov's a smart guy he sees what's
happening to levon ironian in e4
e5 so he very cleverly says ha i will
play the sicilian defense
i'll have none of that please we get
knight f3
e6 d4 takes takes knight c6
knight c3 by fobby a6
and we get knight takes c6 b takes c6
and so with
this change in structure we see fabi
going for a pretty interesting type of
position
against i guess the sicilian here so
whenever you play knight takes c6 and
the sicilian
a lot of you guys maybe as beginners are
told this move is not very good
because it builds black's center up and
allows for an easy
d5 but we're going to see that fabi has
something in mind against it
we have bishop d3 by fabi now d5
castles knight f6 rookie 1
bishop e7 and e5 okay so knight d7 now
and what we have in this instance is
something kind of similar to game one
here fabi is essentially
cutting the board in half with a closed
center
and we saw him do this against levon
aronian in game one
because the king's side was just a more
advantageous side of the board for white
with all those weaknesses he had forced
in the opening
and now fabi uh does it again with with
e5 here
uh so we see the immediate queen g4 and
rather than the preventive approach
preventative approach that we saw
against lemon iranian
uh fabi's just sort of taking the
initiative here and attacking on the
king's side
before black is ready we get king f8 by
black of course castles
would be a pretty big blunder due to
bishop h6 so king f8
is not so unusual now knight a4
by fabi caruana is
keeping an eye on some of these weaker
dark squares
and of course freeing the way for the c
pawn
if c4 or c3 is ever needed
queen a5 by black
don't forget queens move sideways so we
haven't blundered just yet
rookie 2 by favi is a decent move just
getting the work out of the thread of
capture
h5 tries to interrupt this connection
but we just see queen to f4
g5 now continues to try to shake this
queen loose from the knight
and here we're going to see bishop d2
which is really the only move for white
queen c7 now by topolov if you do play g
takes
f4 perhaps this end game is okay for
black
but you have just made quite a few
weaknesses on the king's side
with your h5 g5 nonsense so we see
topalov saving the queen instead and
trying to use this space to launch some
kind of attack
queen g3 h4 queen g4 and now rook g8
uh and after this move uh topalov
is unfortunately already kind of busted
here we see bobby just play rook a to e1
c5 and now this c4 move does come in
handy
this was a large reason why this knight
was moved to a4
you want to be able to contest any sort
of massive center
like the c5 and d5 pawns and you do so
here with white by playing the move c4
d take c4 is topolov's choice rather
than the move
d4 which does come with some problems
here so instead d takes c for
opening up this diagonal and trying to
draw
a white's bishop away from the nasty
attacking diagonal
of b1 to h7 we see bishop b7 now
simply h3 by fabi really taking his time
here making sure there's no threats with
pawn to h3
by black rook d8 bishop c3
knight b8 rook e3 and knight c6 so
topolov is just rerouting the pieces
pretending everything is normal
and attacking the center but of course
fabi's not going to miss a chance to
to attack the black king here so white
to move and
win in this position white kind of has a
small positional edge
regardless of what you do here but fabi
found the best way forward so go ahead
and try to find it
try to find it at home with our last few
minutes
of course the answer here is to continue
sacrificing
bishop takes e6 all fabi does is out
calculate
opponents and sacrifice pieces uh rather
fearlessly
and yet again this is just another game
all from this one tournament
that probably belongs in a best games
collection fabi was just
blasting out these best games of all
time uh back in
back in this 2014 sink field cup uh we
get f takes e6 by topalov rook f3 check
king e8 and now simply queen takes e6
this king is stuck
in the center of the board this rook is
undefended
and the white pieces are all sort of
looming in the position
rook g7 is what topolov tried but now
queen h6
and this rook is kind of just trapped
knight d4
was played in the game going for counter
play but now
e6 and like it's just it's all so nasty
it's all so nasty this stuff we get
knight takes f3 with check
bobby just recaptures and now bishop f8
tries to keep everything together
but queen h5 check king e7 and bishop
takes g7 was enough
for topalov to resign of course if you
capture this bishop
you're going to get checked and e7e8
is just making a second queen for white
and by the way white's only down one
piece
in this position so it's not like white
has to has had to sacrifice
a whole ton of material to get here um
and so i kind of zipped through this
game but the the point i just wanted to
show
is that how easily foggy is is making
these games like look look just
completely winning like
topolov legendary player and played a
pretty reasonable game here there were
some strange stuffs
like this h5 and g5 stuff this rook g8
move king f8 in the opening
definitely open the door for fabi but
then not wasting any time
bobby just sits on the position until
there's one chance for a knockout punch
and then immediately he capitalizes and
just wins the game
rather effortlessly and that is the
story of this whole tournament fabi
making the top 10 grand masters of the
day looking
like weak gms just absolutely dominating
them
in every facet of the game positional
understanding
tactical calculation taking your
opportunities
and even psychologically as we kind of
saw against mvl not mvl's best game
but fabi again just on an absolute tear
in 2014.
now by the way if you are new to the st
louis chess club we
are still hosting the sink field cup and
this year's was just announced a little
bit ago so i recommend
uh stay in tuned uh to our events in the
upcoming year
the sink field cup just one of many
we're hoping to have in the late summer
going in to fall will we see fabi
ever do a repeat showing of his feet
here in 2014
i certainly hope so that's going to do
it for us here tonight on the road 2000
i want to thank you guys very much for
watching if you're watching live we
actually do have a lecture with
grandmaster steven
zirk coming up right after this so look
for that on the same channel
and as always i will see you next time
[Music]
you